Justin Bieber spotted with a mystery
blonde details on their night out bella
thorne gets candid about being labeled a
[ __ ] and Beyonce and jay-z while they're
cruising around Kingston hey guys on
Deni direct oh and Justin Bieber's
rekindled romance with Selena Gomez has
gone cold folks but things seem to be
heating up with another woman the Biebs
has spotted out with the blonde in the
VIP section of a Craig David concert in
LA Tuesday night
all right witness wasit all go down and
got this play-by-play quote blonde keeps
dancing on him he had his arm around her
for a full song and putting his hand on
her behind Justin we have so many
questions like who is the mystery blonde
well we found out she's 22 year old
Victoria's Secret model Baskin champion
and a former Miss Teen Alabama 2014 her
sister is Biebs buddy patrick
Schwarzenegger girlfriend Abby champion
now the other big question is what's the
deal with Selena Gomez then you know
Selena's off in Australia vacationing
with friends trying to keep a low
profile
last week a source told ET they are
taking some time apart but insisted
Jelena we're still together and
apparently that still seems to be the
case today a source tells ET Selena has
pulled back on the relationship to focus
on herself but they haven't officially
split they've simply decided to be quote
together when they're together and apart
when they're apart and if you're
confused by that don't worry I am - to
help unpack it all and bring it in my
girl Angelina expert Katie Krauss Katie
we need your help I mean if you thought
Ross and Rachel were a saga seriously
alright so there's no bad blood between
Justin and Selena but let me ask you
this why get handsy with another woman
in public as you mentioned though Selena
has been in Australia living to her best
life and Justin just want to do the same
our source says quote she's off having
fun with friends and so he's showing
that he can still go out and have fun -
but get this the source also added that
of him want to make Selena a little bit
jealous well that's healthy okay as I
previously told you guys a source told
us that Selena's family and friends
still don't approve of Justin so knowing
that let me ask you how do you think
this will play out like do you think
these two are gonna end up together I
don't know if they're gonna end up
together but I don't think this is a
very end of Jelena I think that they're
both highly scrutinized no matter what
they do their relationship is judged
they're very very much in the spotlight
all the time they can't win but I think
they're both focusing on living their
best life on being better people we see
them exiting the same church constantly
and I think when she does return from
Australia we're probably gonna see them
together in some capacity and we're
still gonna be wondering what the heck
is going on and listen I think
relationships can be casual so I can be
open but knowing Justin and Selena's
history it's way too complicated so full
upon today I love it though but I do
want to move on to another star who
knows exactly what it's like to be young
and under a microscope Bella Thorne
Katie you just caught up with her I did
she's actually in the new movie Midnight
Sun with wait for it patrick
Schwarzenegger six degrees of separation
up in the daily Denny today okay in the
film Bella's character gets labeled a
vampire because she's actually allergic
to the Sun but Bella got candid with me
about the real-life name-calling that
she's experienced in a spotlight I feel
like you've been labeled and there's
been so many misconceptions about you
what's been the most hurtful and kind of
set it straight for us when people look
at you and they're like off you know
dressing a certain way you have to be
covered up or else your ass a lot of
some sort you know I'm whatever they
want to call you whatever demeaning term
they think fits you best and especially
with you know certain people's
backgrounds considering my own you know
those things are taking a little bit
more to heart you know if someone says
like why do you dress that way is it
because something that happened when
you're younger and you're like oh maybe
it actually is oh that's a good point
you know it's like it's it's kind of
those small moments where you're like oh
I wish that didn't dig as deep as it did
yeah that's got to be hard but you
always come out the other side or so it
seems
thank you Wow kind of like selena and
Justin she's very much judged no matter
what she does whether it's a boyfriend
whether it's what she's wearing and I am
impressed by her I mean I've interviewed
her so many times over the years and
she's always candid she's always open
and I just want to say she also credits
some the boyfriend mod son they're
bringing out the positive in her life I
love that but I am waiting for that epic
like triple date now between Patrick and
Abby Bella and mod Justin and Baskin I'm
just saying oh we got thank you so much
you guys can actually catch more of
Katie's interview with Bella and Patrick
I'll throw that up at et online.com
slash daily Deni for you okay Cheers
oh I love it alright moving right along
to some grown folk Beyonce and jay-z are
literally on the run just days after
announcing their on the run to tour the
superstar couple hit the streets of
Kingston Jamaica on Tuesday that's Jay
behind the wheel of a motorcycle with be
riding shotgun she's in a Gucci track
jacket waving and blowing kisses to the
fans as they drove by now the two were
reportedly shooting video content that
will be used for their upcoming joint
tour that's right mom and dad are coming
stateside on July 25th and just added 9
dates to the calendar and I'm happy to
report that I got tickets I got my
tickets guys don't worry I got them I
just can't afford my groceries anymore
so good thing I'm eating like a rabbit
right now Coachella is about three weeks
away and if you can believe it I am on
day 14 of my 21-day vegan diet and going
strong it actually hasn't been that bad
but would Beyonce ever steer me wrong
the answer is no all right guys thanks
for putting up with me I appreciate you
this was a fun show today if you liked
it then comment and share this with your
friends please and I'll be back tomorrow
with more love and peace